Every Sunday night, you become a
productivity guru. Then Wednesday hits
and you're eating cereal for dinner
while binge watching shows you've
already seen. Here's the uncomfortable
truth. You're not failing at discipline
because you're weak. You're failing
because you're trying to solve a systems
problem with a willpower solution. The
most disciplined people aren't actually
disciplined. They've simply designed
their lives so that doing the right
thing is easier than doing the wrong
thing. Your brain treats your future
self like a completely different person.
Sunday you makes promises that Wednesday
you has to keep. Trying harder at
discipline makes you worse at it.
Willpower is like holding your breath
for 16 hours. Eventually, you'll gasp
harder than if you'd been breathing
normally all along. The solution? Don't
change what you do. Change who you are.
You don't need discipline. You need
design.